do you love the great tex-mex taste of
chilies but you hate going all the way
to Chili's then come to Chili's the
easiest way to get Chili's let me get a
crackling hot fajita platter hmm an
order of queso fries yeah and a
raspberry margarita I'll be right back
place your order and I'll go the meters
Chili's for you only 35 minutes by 5 I
take my car but I already have too many
duis while you wait chill out in our
magazine laughs what's your food arrives
I wait for that pesky waiter to leave
and then I place the food and my passion
chilies back and whisking back to you
see it's that chill easy just relax and
wait for me to wait for your food we're
up
go ahead eat I have a drill Easter Bunny
remedy hop hi can I have a bloomin onion
now doesn't have bloomin onion
they have Ostler blossoms what do you
think this is Outback Steakhouse keys
[Music]
[Music]
chattering tonight so ease on down to
Chili's you'll save so much money you'll
be a jillion Chili's it's a breeze
[Music]
really saying something
it's really saying something that's one
of the Dumber things we've shown it off
but it makes me so happy
what a horrible idea
you